but the second he came out Trump is
Hitler I've heard that so many times now
Trump is Hitler I swear if he's anything
short of Hitler I'm gonna be like he did
a pretty good job congratulations
hi I'm Nick Gillespie for reason today
we're talking with Dave Smith he's a
comedian who's got a great special I
called libertas on September 11th and
he's also the host of two podcasts
Legion of skanks and part of the problem
a libertarian comedian Dave Smith thanks
for talking thank you for having me okay
to be here I've made it you would the
table yes is it well the libertarian
buzz Bowl which is a much maligned and
ignored reason TV video starring Chuck
Schumer and four loko vs. juice back
when they were caffeinated nevermind so
talk about libertas it's my first comedy
special I've been doing stand-up for 11
years I'm very proud of it it was
produced by a gas digital network which
is my podcast network and Louis J Gomez
hilarious comedian just a great
entrepreneur who's the guy who started a
stage when he directed it and yep it's
out September 11th he chose that date
not me but uh but I'm excited this is
gonna do for libertarian comedy what
September 11th it was a redevelopment
project according to Paul Krugman who
literally like less than a week after
the 9/11 attacks said you know the
silver lining in in this is that there's
gonna be a lot of building down there
now that's right when is Paul Krugman
never give George W Bush credit for
being such a great president in his mind
right I mean the real the wars I mean
what could you not look how is it how is
it that we were left with such a
wonderful economy it is strange but
we'll talk about Libertas why is it
called that and I've watched it it's
very funny
and what I love about it is that it's a
critique both of trumpism and anti-trump
ISM yes so talk a little bit about how
you came to say okay this is the set
that I want to commemorate and it's just
I mean I think the special is it's
really like the first half of it is kind
of my take on the last year and that the
Trump moment and politics in the second
half is more
my take on the big picture of the
country but yeah I mean I think we live
in like the most profoundly hilarious
times ever
I think the Trump side and the
anti-trump side are both cartoonish and
ridiculous and in this profound
hilarious moment that we live no one it
seems like everyone's like too angry and
dug into their side to enjoy the humor
of all the two questions one how do you
how much when you say the Trump versus
the anti Trump sign psy didn't like
neither Trump nor Hillary could get a
majority in the presidential election
people are leaving the identification
with the Republican or Democratic party
for you know obviously what's taking
them so long but like how much of
America do you think constitutes Trump
and anti Trump like is it forty percent
total is it eighty percent and then what
was the funniest thing or what is the
most bizarre thing about Trump's totally
unpredictable
my gut so it's um I mean if I had to
guess I'd go more like 10 percent and 10
percent most yeah I think there's a big
chunk that's just living their life and
not real run assumed with this the
people who don't vote who don't really
care who don't you know and god bless
those people oh by the way but I think
you know that
yeah the Trump moment of course caught
us all off guard but that's I think what
I really saw out of the left wing which
was interesting over the last year is an
inability to deal with the facts on the
ground and an inability to deal with
anything that doesn't fit their
narrative perfectly so while they're
yelling like Trump's a racist he's this
horrible racist I'm looking at Trump
rallies and he's going you know the
media says we're racist but it's we're
gonna do tremendously well for the black
people look like huge ovations maybe
this is he's not literally Hitler I mean
there's something cartoonish and
ridiculous about I mean Trump is
literally a cartoon yeah literally I
mean from his hair to his skin color to
he's it's like you watching the news and
there's people and then a cartoon
character yeah and the way he talks like
well you know we didn't we had a very
big job it's a very tremendous I mean he
is he talks like a an eighth grader from
like 1945 it's amazing and it's uh it's
it's how I remember
after the james comey thing came out I
just forget exactly how he said it but
he was like he's a hacker he lied
no it was like bullet points for a first
grader but what's equally amazing thing
about Trump is he's like this buffoon
but he holds a mirror up to the entire
system and reveals how buffoonish it all
is so he had this ability to almost like
drag everyone down into the mud and then
when they're all down in the mud you're
like well it's kind of a wash and Trump
kind of belongs in the mud so once
they're swinging insults back and forth
he's winning going into the debates I
was at out of the Republican candidates
I was most favorable towards Rand Paul
me too you know for obvious reasons he
was the most libertarian by far and and
the most interesting I think in terms of
trying to shake up a traditional
Republican thing but like when he would
turn to George - what's the face Jeb
Bush and just be like oh you're low
energy you know and it's like you could
see Jeb Bush almost crying and Ted Cruz
you know like you know his lower lip was
trembling because it was like they
couldn't come back why do you see
anything like that in politics yeah well
first Trump he just outfit him it was
just alpha verse verse beta there was no
but how do you how do you get to be I
mean Jeb Bush was not a minor political
player is a very successful two-term
governor comes from a you know an
aristocratic family in terms of politics
and is it that he had never been
confronted by a tough and not even a
tough guy a clown I I think we something
was exposed that you and him like a
weakness this is not a guy who wants to
fight yeah and Trump is a guy who's like
a fighter
I agree with you I I mean I was like I
Tyson after he got clipped by Buster
Douglas late and then suddenly everybody
could beat him well you know yeah well
there was something that was exposed and
then once that was exposed it was just
like you couldn't go back from that and
um you know but I remember the moment
and Rand Paul I thought was the best
candidate by far not even close by far
in the race and there was this moment
when Donald Trump I must say even I
thought it was my favorite debate
moments ever but Donald Trump goes he
was he was talking about the the
trans-pacific partnership and how he's
against it and he goes the trans-pacific
partnership does not address China's
currency manipulation and that's the
problem and Rand Paul no moderator Rand
Paul because should someone point out
that China is not a part of the TPP yeah
so it's an agreement between US Japan
and South Korea we can enjoy another and
Sabra in this and um well and he was
pointing out that it was an attempt to
hem in China in yes in the Pacific yeah
of course we can't make a deal if they
are currency and agreement that they're
not in and then Donald Trump goes Rand
Paul is that less than 1% yeah it was
just like oh I guess Trump won that
moment yeah that's where we're at but
that is that is hilarious well you know
in an tragic in the special you you talk
about Trump's ability to kind of just
wing it and like you talked about the
[ __ ] grabbing comments and stuff and
it's like once he says that and like the
world doesn't end the sky doesn't fall
and he isn't rushed off the stage it's
like anything goes talked a little bit
about that and about you know what is it
that Trump Trump clearly exposed the
weakness of conventional politicians to
you know kind of talk back to people who
are kind of in their face but what else
does Trump bringing to political
discourse well well you I think you're
absolutely right right like he's so he's
bringing this um this this unscripted
this idea that I'm not playing with in
what was the agreed-upon parameters like
we're gonna be out here I can just you
know say whatever I want to you and
politicians have a very tough time
they're all like scripted robots so they
have an amazing time struggling with
that the other thing that's like really
really interesting about all of it and
this is kind of Mike Mike critique on
the left and I know you can really
relate to this because like as
libertarians right so you're somebody
who's been here writing about that for
years like you know criticizing Obama
for your calling me old I'm just this
like elder bit since the 30s you were
writing yeah but you see you're I
thought that Wendell Willkie and not
such a good guy you say you look very
critical of Obama's deportations for him
being at war every day of the
administration and then like Trump comes
out and he's like we're gonna deport
people we're gonna bomb the heck out of
them and the Liberals are like freaking
out and you're like but like your guy
who you're celebrating is the greatest
president ever is doing this and one of
the things Trump exposed is that like
it's his words that they're so offended
by what Meryl Streep actually how out of
touch are you when you go it was the mo
meant that he made fun of a reporter
with a weird arm like okay chunk
shouldn't have done that but like was
this the moment forget starting a war
that was unnecessary
this is like the the sin of all sins
well that's far I'm sure it's like South
Park would mr. garrison you know as a
transgendered Trump candidate makes a
sexist joke there's something and then
people are like ah that's it I'm out
what took you so that was the most
brilliant
I thought political comment ever when
they go when he said the grabbing by the
post II thing then people started
storming out and mr. garrison who's
trying I think he goes oh did that do it
for ya not the [ __ ] it's the death
right and that was what an amazing
comment though unlike our society it's
like oh yeah no you can I don't actually
care about people being victimized and
being impressed but I need to be the one
who cares about that just don't talk
about it so do it quietly two things and
first does does Trump's rhetoric though
where he makes explicit in in many ways
in terms of blowing up Middle Eastern or
third-world countries in terms of
deporting illegal immigrants you know
he's only making explicit what Barack
Obama did but is he also playing to a
kind of tribalist native this racist
sentiment in America or maybe not maybe
tribalist is better yeah and then what
is it about the well you know talk about
that is that part of what he's
motivating in America yes I think yes I
mean like didn't obviously yeah to a
large degree but I don't like racism is
a very very broad term so you can have
you can have somebody who's you know but
by today's microaggressions standard I
mean anything not politically correct as
racist but yeah I mean look a preference
for your own or wanting to live around
your own is something that you know a
lot more of us have then we actually
voice if you just look at real estate
and self segregation and things like
that a lot of people now you know I'm
like a person who's from a city and
always lived around a lot of groups of
people but I think a lot of people in
the middle of the country look at the
demographic changes in Hawaii and don't
like that have you have you spent any
time in the middle of the country I have
as a stand-up comedian I that's one of
the things I've been able to do is I've
traveled all over these will only go to
you go to whites only comedy clubs or
are they effectively whites only common
no
tell you something I've been I've done
quite a few black rooms Spanish rooms in
my life and lots of mixture to see when
I mixed room speckled they yes because
yeah the only ones but I like them to be
completely secular yeah though though
that's you know that's that you know
that's Malcolm X meeting George Lincoln
Rockwell that's like you know they both
agreed on segregation right so what do
you what what is the response from a
libertarian perspective to that to that
kind of dynamic and Trump well I thought
and and I think this really says
something because I think Hillary
Clinton is like one of the worst
candidates you could possibly like just
absolutely horrific would have been a
nightmare and I'd very it was Trump was
disqualifying for me I was you know I
just couldn't get on board with that and
I would have loved to be able to get on
board with any anti-hillary you know
anyone who had a real shot of beating
Hillary was very tempting to me but no I
mean just as you said I mean once you
once you start talking about mass
deportations targeting families bringing
torture back I mean these things to me
were too profoundly on libertarian for
so but what is how do you convince I
guess what I'm asking how do you
convince Trump supporters that like you
know this guy is kind of [ __ ] up like
this is you know this this isn't good
and it's like they're you know this
doesn't have a good ending well I mean I
don't know I guess you know at this
point you couldn't start looking at the
facts on the ground and and you know I
mean look he's done some spectacular
things he's done more than any other
president ever that's right I was
winning yeah well look I mean I I like
to point out the the obvious [ __ ] of
Trump so I really enjoyed making fun of
some of my ultralite friends who you
think I'm too sympathetic to you but I
when Trump made that trip and he went to
Saudi Arabia and then to Israel I was
just laughing at all of them I've had a
whole podcast and how do you guys feel
he just yeah a hundred a hundred million
in weapons excuse me hundred billion and
weapons to to the most radical Islamists
on the country and then he went and
kissed the ring of all your Jew friends
in Israel so I think it's like yeah
Trump Trump had a brilliant insight he
saw an opening and played to it Trump is
not that guy Trump was a Hillary Clinton
supporter he's not
this is all but he's not a [ __ ] right
because he what he's doing is he's
turning me all right into [ __ ] because
they'll follow him you know to the the
gates of hell I believe there is a lot
of coquetry on the authorized yeah
casket tree that's even better I think
in a lot of ways and I've said this very
consistently I think the alt-right
mirror social justice warriors they're
like they're equal opposite but they're
very similar in a weird way it reminds
me I remember when the men's rights
movement thing popped up you know and it
kind of be like like the feminists would
be out there like we need these programs
for women and government programs for
women and then the men's rights activist
would be like we need government
programs for men and your permit of
action like this is insane so I play see
a lot and they have well and and there's
the Trump kind of the trumpian version
of political correctness which I'm sure
you got in any any any time you write or
commit to public speaking you know
people are like shut up you know you're
you're a commie you're this you're that
if you're not balls deep with your nose
up Trump's ass and I realize that
doesn't make any sense but it's you know
but but you know but it's like then that
means you're a communist and you know
you were the one who transported Obama's
birth certificate from Kenya to Hawaii
or something like that and it's kind of
like just who did that but yes no III
agree with you know the same way the
left has like this virtue signaling
thing where everyone's got it like James
they're they're you know profile yeah
sure to fight for 15 to let you know I'm
on the right side so that the the
alt-right Internet guys have like anti
virtue signaling so it's like whoever
can be the most hardcore like I throw
the Jews in the oven of anyway yeah
you're the man and it's like you're
doing the same thing they're doing but I
do think like I've had this feeling for
a long time which really drives me crazy
in America this is very true on the left
is is Larry was saying with Trump like
this thing where words are the worst
thing in the world right like saying
something offensive is horrific like if
you were to go like I just think Muslim
culture is violent you're like you got
to go but if you went Islam is a
religion of peace and then you bomb the
crap out of like your okay so I hate
that and what I don't like in like the
libertarian world is this thing where
it's like oh I have to come out and like
repudiate like I have to make it clear
that I'm not a Nazi what
like the most obvious thing ever I'm a
Jew preaching for individual rights who
hates the state what's less Nazi than
that but it's like I have to say I have
to like condemn the alt-right because
they've said me in words meanwhile our
party can run like a guy who supported
the war in Iraq is their VP who opened
opened the campaign supporting Kasich
you know who's like a war hawk and then
we can have a guy who's saying Jews have
to build bake Nazi cakes as our as our
nominee and these people who aren't
outraged about that are like outraged
that someone said no no words I just
don't I don't have that same that same
like so did you vote for did you vote
for Gary Johnson no did you vote did not
I made a whole video about how I don't
think you should ever know there's other
why oh why are we talking about voting
why are you talking about voting this is
well because it's a pretty you might as
well be talking to me about having sex I
mean it's like you know if we're just
gonna talk about stuff that's not
happening well no because no matter what
whether I vote or not the winner of that
election does rule over me so it's
relevant so you're happy then that at
least two of three candidates that you
disliked lost Gary Johnson and Hillary
well I guess in a sense no look Gary
Johnson certainly would have been
preferable to these guys I'm not denying
that but as a third party candidate you
have to do a little bit more than be
preferable I'm not looking at you as the
lesser of two evils the what I'm talking
about is not democracy or because yeah
I'm talking about libertarian principles
yeah and where you're outraged should
lie like if I'm looking at all these
sites and yeah if there's someone
marching with Kerry was pretty good on
you know he clearly was not gonna bomb a
bunch of foreign countries right that's
for sure no yes look if I thought there
was a reasonable chance that Gary
Johnson would have gotten it I mean look
I think you got a booty goddamn phone
you would have woken up that time yeah
okay maybe convince me if you're gonna
be a third party you got to convince me
and when you're sitting there and you're
running away from your own philosophy
constantly and then apologizing for like
how terrible it would be so we're just
was there a libertarian candidate early
on that you would have voted for just
and not as virtuous signaling because
it's not you know I mean I voted for
Gary Johnson cuz he was the best
candidate out of the ones who were there
I don't think that my vote ever swings
an election but you know I like to
express it was reference I was open to
to voting for Rand Paul at the beginning
I mean he'd admit to the New York
primary but I was I I voted for Ron Paul
yeah and I would I would vote again for
ya well he's a little old tell me well
you know he's is he that much older than
Trump for years he's still working
harder than he was in Congress the guy
puts out like two articles a week it's
like always on TVs yes he's a beast so
talk about the left's inability to deal
with you you've talked about this and
that what it what I love about the
special and it's not like a false
equivalence or anything but like it's
great to see somebody making fun of
Trump and understanding Trump and also
enjoying Trump on some level but then
the discombobulation on the left is
amazing and you know they used to back
in the day they were you know fond of
talking about being part of the
reality-based community and all of this
and and now you have you know people who
just can't it doesn't compute reality no
longer computes for that I don't know
what happened to the left over the last
10 years like I don't know what they
went off the rails and I thought when I
first came into libertarianism I thought
overall the left was a little bit better
than the right like I don't believe in
this false equivalency thing and I was
like well you know they're pretty
passionately against war and mass
incarceration and like those are kind of
the most important issues to me so but I
just look at the right over the last ten
years and I think by and large even if
you want to focus on the 50 crazies in
charlottesville by large I think the
right-wing has gotten a lot better from
a libertarian perspective there they're
much less hawkish they're cooler about
gay marriage they're less pushing
religion most of them have kind of
retreated to libertarian positions so
like if instead of like you really
hearing people like we have to overturn
roe v wade they're like I don't want my
tax dollars going to Planned Parenthood
that's a to a libertarian a very
reasonable compromise
oh I don't gay marriage can be the law
of the land but I don't have to bake you
a cake if I don't want like these any
libertarian you wouldn't care if it's
freely off I'll eat a cake with a
swastika on it I like cake okay I just
don't want gay doesn't make me bake one
if I don't want to but anyone does
anybody want now the left wait you say
you're baking a lot of swastika cakes
I'm just saying it's but you're not
around pro-nazi right okay
they're paying for these cakes I mean
listen but no I'm just saying so and
then in the meantime they all pay is
gold Swiss gold
I take Bitcoin but so the left then has
gone from being anti-war to like yeah
okay that kind of went away and now it's
like Trump could bomb the third world
tomorrow and then make remarks that are
offensive to transgender people and they
wouldn't even care about the first well
or they would say and this happened
after Syria that oh you know Trump
became presidential today oh my god
because he bombed a couple of air strips
and like a Dunkin Donuts somewhere in
Syria as much as the media's been
convincing me and you could watch CNN
all day or suddenly that they're
convincing you know how outraged you
should be about Trump nothing has
outraged me more than the media coverage
of his bombing of Syria it was the most
disgusting thing I've ever seen in my
life and I've just been more to meet
Trump has and I didn't think anyone
could but he has exposed the media even
more than I thought they were exposed
like I've never been so disgusted CNN's
gonna sit here every day and talk about
how like we're so concerned that
somebody would like undermine democracy
you leaked debate questions to Hillary
Clinton you did you undermine democracy
in the most profound way and you haven't
even apologized they do they just move
on like that's no big deal it's like man
Trump it is it is terrifying that this
guy's in control of the military but
like what's even more equally terrifying
is that you're you guys are covering it
so how old are you if you don't mind man
34 are you and your lamp's say that as
comedian so do we add seven years what
is what's the typical comedian actresses
lion ears comedians no we don't care
okay so you're you're a solid millennial
right I guess yes yeah and that means
that you I mean you in a way I mean it
kind of sucks to be you because you've
grown up in a world that is only known
like non-stop conflict and it's not even
good conflicts like nobody's pretending
that the world has really held in
balance between Iraq or Afghanistan I
mean it's not like it's not the cold
where it's not even the [ __ ] and
Olympics or Boris Spassky playing Bobby
Fischer in chess or like nothing really
matters but it's always on in the
background shitty economic growth the
one thing that's really clarified for
Millennials is that you got I assume
then you got to see Bush in action and
he's conservative and then we elect
Obama and he's everything that Bush
isn't but does exactly the same stuff
biggest story that isn't that nobody's
talking about right now
with with Trump is like just what you're
saying like how much is the same I mean
so much is the same like yes it's a
little bit different what you see on TV
he's using Twitter he's doing this or
like all the things we care about like
like foreign policy monetary policy
fiscal policy like all of these things
are exactly the same from Bush to Obama
to Trump like as different as you could
be and we're still it's like Obama Bush
broke the records in terms of spending
and then Obama broke his records and
guess what Trump's gonna do he's gonna
break Obama's record so then why are
Millennials so totally in the in the
tank for Democratic presidential
candidates and granted you know there's
only three of them basically you know
and it's fascinating Bush versus Gore in
2000 they basically split the
male-female vote they split the youth
vote I mean it was you know kind of
even-steven but now it's like they're I
mean are any Millennials if they vote
for a major party will they ever vote
Republican again I don't think so
I mean not any but yeah in terms of like
major you know demographic trends yeah
we're talking like two-thirds you know
or more I mean if you think I think like
if you kind of look at the what was
going on in college campuses in the 60s
and then kind of the generation that
that came after that I mean like what's
going on in college campuses right now I
don't see the thing like a conservative
trajectory for young people no I think I
don't know what it is but socialism
leftism all of that it's it's really
great propaganda and it spreads like
wildfire and it's very popular with
young people and like I don't know I
don't see anything I see that going more
that Bernie Sanders wing has all the
energy so how does Bernie Sanders you
know and I always thought of Bernie
Sanders and Ron Paul as kind of
interesting because they're their old
kind of nice guys you know I mean Larry
not nice guy I mean Bernie is always
huffin and puffin he's like pure
Brooklyn yeah you know bathed in a you
know at Ben and Jerry's like cream bath
or something in Vermont but you know
he's he and Ron Paul are interesting
because they're not charismatic speakers
no but they're also very idealistic
that's right and they both like latch
into kids like what what is going on
there I I hated that about Bernie
Sanders because I thought so much of it
almost like erased the Ron Paul memory
because it was aesthetically almost like
you know from a conspiratorial
did they just try to copy this but make
a lefty version of it because it was it
was like a kind of disheveled older guy
who's just a truth teller
like I'm not really up here concerned
with like making the perfect speech it's
like let me tell you what's going on but
then you look at the major differences
and not just that like they're the the
difference between me to me in the two
of them is that so Ron Paul was going
around like so someone like me who came
into the Ron Paul this is how I became a
libertarian through the Ron Paul
movement he challenged all of my
preconceived notions about what
government was he inspired me to like
read all of these people you know like
Rothbard and Mises and Friedman and all
of these great thinkers and and think
about all of these things that he has
kids chanting end the Fed you know
you're you've read a few books if you're
chanting and the Fed would patch Bernie
would go around these kids and be like
hey so you're you're a college kid in
2017 you're amongst the richest freest
most privileged people who have ever
existed billionaires should be paying
your bills for you I mean it's like he
just played into everything they like so
it was the difference between a
propagandist and and like a truth it's
also kind of interesting to thinking
back to some earlier comments we had
Sanders also talked about the economy
more like he he is not a hardcore
identitarian like he's not a social
justice warrior he is in terms of the
minimum wage and unions and you know you
know he's always afraid of Pinkertons
coming in and busting up you know a
union meeting or something but he's not
talking about you know transgender
rights and stuff like that or anything
he was attacked by blacks live yeah I
mean he got pushed off the stage
literally in Seattle oh that's right I'm
early on because he wasn't sensitive
enough well that's right and also he did
I mean he did very poorly with the
minority vote Hillary killed him I think
Bernie Sanders is more attracted to this
kind of old-school
economic socialist argument and he's not
so into the cultural market argument
where we've changed the the oppressor
and oppressed to race and gender so he
still sees it through this like no no
it's the billionaire class and the
economic it's really it's that uncle
moneybags yeah it's all the same thing
because it's just it's this forced
Marxist way of looking at the world as
everything is a presser versus oppressed
and it's like it's it's utterly ignorant
how do you well how do you reach
Millennials and I'm assuming you know as
a comedian and through your podcasts and
whatnot
talk about those in some detail you know
how do you how do you reverse this or
are you just kind of like you know what
it's it's over and I'm just gonna enjoy
myself while it lasts but I mean like
how you know is the question that you
know your cohort your generation doesn't
remember history or they have forgotten
it or are they like actually they're
knowledgeable and they've embraced
something that has been proven wrong I
mean how do you engage people like you
say Ron Paul you know if it took a you
know an 800 year old obstetrician to get
you to rethink your premises what are
you gonna do to make people your same
age think differently that's a really
great question I think you always like I
love doing the podcast and talk you know
I'm like I'm a New Yorker and I'm I was
raised by a single mother and I'm just
so I kind of speak their language
inherently so I feel like I can I can
talk to Millennials in that sense and I
just thought to me I make the argument
that I find compelling but I look at
like for libertarianism in terms of
spreading the ideas I mean the people
who did the most ever like just
undoubtably are like iron Rand and she
did it through novels I don't think
that's today's America you know I don't
think that's how you're gonna reach a
babe and that was in that time that was
how you could reach a lot of people like
Milton Friedman had that TV series free
to choose and and a book to match I
think the TV series probably converted
more people than the book a big deal
it's like there was a companion to the
TV show to me I think like I I do kind
of look at podcasting today as being
like to some degree like the meat now
how can you become the on random
snapchat I Instagram my god IP this
[ __ ] still with social media where
snapchat it might be one of my new
nicknames alright well you just need a
stat a snapchat account now and then
somebody to tell you how to work you
know think of it it you're already there
because like your messages disappear of
media or if you know in time and you
know you were already are you leaving
that the ripple behind them and I can't
complain about I guess there is a case
you know I actually talked to two people
made comments to libertarians made
comments that really stuck with me one
was at a reason event where Katherine
was speaking Katherine mangu war editor
of the print edition
that's correct Ruth and she said she
said you know no matter how frustrated
we get with the growth of the state you
always have to remember that the market
is growing as well
and that we're living it like a better
time than anyone's ever lived and we
have more wealth so I think it's very
important for libertarians to always
remember that to like the state but
there's also all this great stuff that's
going on here that we live through and
the other thing was what Ron Paul just
convinced me that he said that
libertarians absolutely should be
optimistic and he said that we should
have the case for optimism is stronger
than the case for pessimism and I just
took it as a guy like him who's been
around this game for a long time is kind
of seen it all and I think America might
be on the way to to a crack-up but like
when the USSR cracked up that was
probably the best thing that ever
happened to the to the Russian people
and the Ukrainian people and you know so
so maybe the fact that like maybe this
whole thing can kind of come unglued in
in a positive way and we still we're not
gonna just not have the technology
anymore like that's gonna be there so
maybe we can figure all this as like the
idea that yeah you know the Roman Empire
fell and that was bad for the Romans but
it wasn't so bad for other people right
right and and and right and and you
could see very clearly was good for the
Huns
yeah yeah and but no it's not it's not
so great for you know people maybe they
are invested in government bonds or
something like that like there's gonna
be a lot of damage problems but I think
even like um you see like just having
interest rates as low as we have for all
these years you're like okay so we don't
have to feel the crash but you're
punishing all the savers everybody on a
fixed income and rewarding all the
speculators so like there is still pain
going on and it's not the people who
deserve to be feeling the pain your
podcasts you you do a podcast called
part of the problem which is a political
one and then you also do the Legion of
skanks that's right which are filthy
comedy okay so let's talk about the
filthy comedy first and then if we have
time we'll get to the libertarian
politics but so and these are on the gas
digital network yes what is the best
place for people to find the gas digital
network it's a guess it'll network calm
right there there you go - jeez -
essence GA s digital network calm what
what do you talk about on legion of
skanks legion of skanks will just be
whatever it's just it's me
Louis J gomez and Jay oakerson two of
the just funniest comedians out there
and we're just over the top we try to
find comedy in the most tragic fucked-up
things and like name one we one time we
did this
what's called the gauntlet we have to
just sit there and watch the most
horrific videos that are on the Internet
and just just our reactions to like who
could break down first and look away and
stuff like so we go over the top but but
it's just just comics kind of talking
[ __ ] having fun that's not nothing too
serious and then part of the problem is
my outlet rant and rave about what's
going in the world and this is where
recently or with in recent memory you've
had Christopher Cantwell the former
member of the Free State Project who got
kicked out of that years ago for
basically saying hey you know it's it's
you know not just a you know you're not
just justified in shooting tax
collectors you're kind of required to
write and they're like okay let's take
this and then he was the kind of star he
was the he was the Jimmy J Jay Walker of
the Charlottesville March a night the
right route and it was a he made quite a
crazy transition I mean I remember
seeing Christopher Cantwell videos from
like three four years ago where he was
you know railing against police
brutality and how they oppressed the
black community he was a huge fan of
Patrice O'Neal rather you know a famous
black comedian and and he was he was
racially radicalized over the last so
yeah what I mean having talked to him
and I know and you you have a great well
you have the interview with Cantwell and
then you have a podcast after that
talking about where people were like you
were too chummy well yeah well which
both of these are pretty interesting but
did you do you have a strong sense of
like how does somebody and and
Cantwell's like a New York guy write
originally but and he's in his he's in
his mid to late 30s obviously like he's
weepies lachrymose in a way that he
speaks not toxic masculinity but some
kind of personality problem I I suspect
or disorder but how does somebody become
racially you know kind of operationalize
or actualize especially now I mean like
and if you're like you know if you're
from New York and stuff like who the
[ __ ] has time to be racist I I mean look
I I certainly don't exactly understand
that and it's it's one of the things
that I actually found really fascinating
about Christopher Cantwell is like how
could anybody who's accepted like the
non-aggression principle and
libertarianism take this this turn any
super anti-semitic to
he's got like Christopher Campbell has
this thing where he's uh first of all he
is a very talented writer he's very
funny guy and you almost sometimes can't
tell you can't separate what the joke is
and what the reality is and I tried to
ask him as a couple Simon Christopher
Kimmel and this is a comedian first
because that's what really a comedian
first he I emailed him after he had sent
me something and then I emailed him it
was the day after the the
charlottesville thing and I said hey you
want to come on my podcast give your
side of the story and he said I wouldn't
miss it for an autographed copy of mine
comp yeah and it's just like it just
makes me laugh man like you know it's
kind of [ __ ] up but so he's got that
so he's like now it's Jones like is he a
performance artist or something more
Michael Savage first himself is like a
racist shock jock yeah so like he's kind
of doing a thing and I had look I had
Richard Spencer on my show I had him on
my show and I just I find it kind of
interesting and I finally take
interesting and I don't know you're just
asking questions it's also you find it
interesting that World Trade Center 7
obviously a controlled demolition I
always I make it pretty clear where I
stand people who listen to my podcast
now no doubt about where I stand on all
these issues and the same thing I say
when I go on a fox news panel with some
guy who's a CIA killer or somebody who's
you know advocating for the next war I
go in there I I mean I don't know I
never get accused of being chummy with
them so why all the sudden I have to I
have to play this left-wing game where
like I go in and I talk to John bolt and
then I go no that's it that's a
completely legitimate point we should
fight five more Wars that would be
Christopher Cantwell you said a no-no
word just so everyone knows I'm not with
him do you think though that you know
Cantwell was part of a broadly defined
libertarian movement Richard Spencer
talked about how Ron Paul was the guy
who actualized them into politics do
libertarians have a special
responsibility in the same way that the
left does to the anta fire and Tifa I'm
just I'm sorry okay this is what pisses
me off okay Richard Spencer and
Christopher Cantwell are persona non
grata they can't go anywhere is that
Mexican I didn't know I said well they
speak English like these guys can't even
get their own rallies okay they
literally can't even get up thank you
there's not one can
institution that would have them they
don't have any of these television shows
unless they're just slamming them on the
other hand the left you have
full-fledged Marxist tenured professors
so I'm sorry if they're lecturing us
what we need to get rid of our radicals
but you have like three people who came
in from libertarianism don't you get
tired though of when people say things
and this was you know I find you know
anybody who's carrying a Nazi flag
unless they're in a road a touring
company of the you know the sound of
music it's like you know that's sad and
it's pathetic and but people were like
oh you know they're doing as long as
they're doing it at a private function
like we should have no opinion no that's
of course the answer that with a lot of
libertarians where it's like short it's
a private business
it goes to [ __ ] libertarians make the
mistake that the only opinion that makes
you a libertarian is like you shouldn't
be thrown in a cage for it right doesn't
mean I can't sit there and tell you it's
not repugnant and yeah if anyone who
would March with a swastika or a hammer
and sickle
I just find it all like what about their
Stars and Bars that federal flag I don't
love it yeah it's not the same thing I
wouldn't equate that to the same thing
as that you know that mean that's
represents other things to people but
these are like not American about the
rainbow flag Flags all right flags are
like I don't know like a 20th century
invention but so like for you you and I
thought you uh I read your article about
this on the gateway the libertarianism
being the gateway and you it was I think
you quoted somebody in the article but
making the point that the the guy who
organized this came in through occupy
right right so why don't ya well how
about we talk about is our college
campuses a gateway to antifa yeah how
about that
I mean how many of these Antipa kids
were studying in some from some
left-wing professor yeah so why do they
never have to have any of this pressure
but then we got to sit here why should
should we should and we shouldn't
because this is nonsense or we're
preaching something that is as you point
out in your in your article the
antithesis of National Socialism sit
here and talk about you guys are
preaching Muslims actually when you put
it that way we're not nationalists and
we're not socialists so it's the object
as I said people have natural rights the
state is an amoral institution I mean
how
is any of this compatible Nazism do you
worry about you know well when you go to
comedy clubs is there a sense and you've
been doing it now for over a decade
is there a rising sense for you that
certain things are just not tolerated
anymore certain types of speech certain
types of thoughts and does this go be
you know like you get you get a lot of
people who say like oh you know what
it's like now because of political
correctness I can't use my you know
racial epithet of choice and like oh you
know my freedom is being you know
irreparably damaged that's one thing but
I mean you know on college campuses and
you see it's something like Evergreen
State College with in recent memory
where people you know we're patrolling
the campus with baseball bats scaring
people there's a thug's video of all
over the place and Tifa does this they
did it in Berkeley just you know
recently and oh but is there when it
comes to comedy and when it comes to
more substantive thought processes do
you think something is changing where
people are you know and it's not just
different it's new that we're shutting
down disk I've I've noticed it in the
ten years I've been doing comedy and I
think anybody who's been doing stand-up
for those ten years would agree with me
it was like when I first started there
was not this thing of like there are no
no words and no no topics that if you if
you approach the audience is gonna get
tired on and just like you said before
just because something is a cultural
issue and and it doesn't mean we can't
have an opinion on it as libertarians
and I got to say and I don't really love
this narrative because I always want the
state to be the enemy but in 2017 the
threat to free speech is like this
left-wing culture where like Condoleezza
Rice whom he and you probably consider
like a leftist can't even speak on a
college campus because she's like one
step to the right of Hillary Clinton or
something like that like it that that to
me is a very scary trend and but with
the stuff with the culture and comedy
I've noticed it but what sucks about it
is like it's not like oh we've we've
grown and now we're a little bit more
involved so we realize that minorities
are hurt by these insensitive look I've
got all around like black shows and poor
areas minorities feelings are they don't
care they like a good joke it's like
college white kids who are going so I
can feel better as a human being
to be offended by no no words and it's
not it's not the what your intent or
what you're saying it's just if you say
the wrong words they get offended by you
I mean it's like you know it's utterly
ridiculous well to kind of bring this
lively conversation to a close do you
hope that your special airing on
September 11th and it's available on
basically every digital platform you can
we go to the gas digital network to to
rent it and check it out it's very good
I highly recommend it
you know do you hope it'll it'll like
kind of open things up a little bit
that'll you know kind of hit people in
the head with a cartoon mallet and you
know belong and people will understand
we need to be a little bit looser just
as we need to be looser in the economy
we need to be looser at the borders we
need to be looser about drugs can we be
looser about thought I'd love to like to
have that effect on people and I hope so
I do agree with you I think we need to
be looser on all these things I want to
just like my goal is always just to put
out a hilarious comedy special that's
just what I want to do I want to make
great comedy specials and I want you
know I want this to be great and the
next one to be great the next one to be
great and I'm obsessed with this so that
comes out in you know what I'm what I'm
talking about but yeah I think like I
kind of feel like like we need like a
cultural move like we want a culture
that supports Liberty you know what I
mean like that's kind of what we want
and I think it's not a bit I just I love
the idea of like libertarian musicians
but I know there's this guy Eric July at
this band backwards they're like
phenomenal with a Z that's right hackers
with a Z yeah and he's like crazy it's
it's a his story is live phenomenal he's
like this kid who was a gangbanger who
then found Thomas Sol and then found a
libertarian writing and like that and
then that it's amazing um but I think by
the way I want to say as somebody who
roomed at college was a guy who was
really into Christian rock just be
careful what you wish for okay if you
want a libertarian music yeah well I'll
tell ya but he's actually he's one of
the guys and I think I try to do this
with my special - it's not like
something where I'm forcing a
libertarianism at you and then there'll
be a little joke here that it's like
this is comedy I'm doing comedy and it
happens to be a libertarian doing it so
I don't know that you know what it's
gonna have but I think we all have our
little impact like what you guys do with
Podcast what'd you do with the magazine
what everyone does like you know we all
have a little impact on our audience so
and hopefully I get this ooh the big an
audience as possible all right well we
will be doing our best to see that that
happens thank you sir
we've been talking with Dave Smith he's
a comedian he's got a great special out
libertas and he I'm the gasps digital
network look for it on all of your
favorite digital platforms he's also the
proprietor or the host of two podcasts
Legion of skanks and part of the problem
Dave Smith thanks so much for talking
thank you that for reason I'm Nicolas
tee
[Music]